[Music]
do you think they'll ever be a woman
navy seal
thanks for the easy question man
um
you know i think uh because we're
integra for sure women are being more
integrating into the fighting force and
i'm i'm curious they've been shoulder to
shoulder on the battlefield we haven't
we've had them on target a lot their
capacity for work is through the roof do
i think a female can get through seal
training i do i think the thing that
that i want to take slowly when it comes
to the elite units is is that culture
that brotherhood that we talk about is
real and it's a very spartan place the
gentleman i am with my my bride my
family and and you know a woman at a
restaurant or at a table is not the
person i am at a seal team and so how
that culture happens and and stays elite
and capable in a co-ed locker room i'm
not sure so i think we just need to take
time so there's stuff that's going down
that you think is just you're much more
comfortable being around a guy yeah
describe describe what we're talking
about stuff about what happened in the
locker room yes
uh well one thing i would say maybe a
little gross but if we're down my team's
been down in jungles in central and
south america and africa and there are
health and comfort checks you need to do
to make sure you know bugs haven't
crawled into certain parts of your body
to lay eggs and the things that happen
in
nasty places in the world i cannot
imagine doing that with a female
teammate and there's parts of my
teammates bodies i hope to never see
again and uh i think that'd be
challenging guys you're checking each
other out i mean you're you're you're
lifting things and spreading yeah you
know good things you need to do yep
lifting yeah buddy there's oh clinton
there are things you don't want to do
yeah yeah
you got it you got it it's almost like
you've done it before
i'm just making up
random hand movements
i'm doing anything i can think of the
christ like no